[Musik]
das was gerade nicht verstanden hat und
ich glaube das konnte man nicht
verstehen
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen blog meine damen und herren wir
sind schon gekommen weil block 2 nummer
vier
oder schon fünf auf jeden fall waren
jude und ich gerade schon im pool weil
es sind bei uns 33 grad außerdem kamen
die post schon heute an und hat mit das
heißt ich kann mir bei dem ball machen
bei nintendogs und die selbst bereitete
eingeblendet freunde haben wir werden
heute bei verschiedenen läden geschäften
restaurants anrufen und uns krank melden
obwohl die prüfer komisch geatmet wer
diese verschiedenen unternehmen anrufen
und uns krank melden obwohl wir doch gar
nicht arbeiten
ich bin gespannt wie die reagieren
werden bevor wir das allerdings tun
freunde fahren und ich zusammen fans in
die stadt welt ich muss mir wenn's
kaufen und neues hemd und schuhe sein
paket also komplett
in der innenstadt und bielefeld cool
oder die show hätte gern julians events
gekauft und viele leute kommen und
fragen helga was trägst eigentlich so
viele sachen eigentlich nur mehr also
seitdem ich auf instagram bisschen mehr
so auch fashion sachen trage am freue
mich viele leute was ist daran habe
deswegen nicht gerade voll halte oxford
sohnes der einen harmlosen 1 und die
hammer geil und t-shirt das alles kann
die heißt auf instagram laser luca
fühlst du dich erst mal im fernsehen
halo the beach club dass gar keine
flipflops an klar wie ich glaube das ist
gut kappel
ich habe mir überlegt sich nur nudeln
bestellt sondern noch pizza weil ich
habe aber gesagt es noch eine vierte
person kommt und das ist weil es mir
peinlich ist wieder zu hause angekommen
und flach wie was machen wir
richtig wir warten erstmal noch auf
sandra b
[Musik]
jetzt kommen wir auch endlich mal auch
den titel zu sprechen wäre da und zwar
sarah sitzt auch noch da vorne übrigens
wir sind hier zu viert am start also
sarah sandra und jule und ich und wir
werden bei verschiedenen restaurants
deutschlandweit oder bei irgendwelchen
planung weltsport leben oder clubs oder
friseurin oder canvas anrufen und werden
so tun als ob diese arbeiten etwas sagen
hey du ich kann jetzt leider nicht mehr
kommen das heißt ich würde sagen sarah
fängt an und kann morgen nicht kommen
welche freund schluss gemacht hat
leider heißt lisa
[Musik]
ja ich hab's lisa ich muss immer zwei
heißt sie hier ist die sache hat gestern
mit ihm schluss gemacht
ja genau das kategorisch nein aber das
geht ja jetzt nicht
danke dass du nicht arbeiten
als nächstes hallo ich bin ich wollte
zum fensterputzen kommt es richtig
spricht dann ja genau und völkermords
umwelt fensterputzen komme ich auf das
mit ihrem start geklärt wie hat mich
nämlich immer eine firma an sport und
ich wollte fragen weil nicht er immer
und kommen so in 15 oder 16 uhr was
passt besser
ja wir wissen dass nicht ich hab das mit
ihm schenkt abgeklärt ich kleine termine
aber nicht bis zum sommer warten
mit ihrem chef von mir wurde gesagt ich
soll morgen gegen 15 uhr 16 uhr bei
ihnen die fenster putzen alles gleich
kommt es zu 16 arbeiten sie mir die tür
nicht offen lassen da bin ich sauer
halle klar ja alles klar ich komme
morgen vor allem kredite bei restaurants
krank werden dort nicht arbeiten
sara wir sagen die sagen jetzt diese
haare schon einen termin ab und sandra
wir silvester kurz gekommen als nächstes
trifft schule bei einer eisdiele an
[Musik]
hallo hier ist die carola muss man über
ihn um 15 uhr ein probearbeiten aber ich
kann mich ganz doll die grippe habe nur
das hat echt ein bisschen verwegen es
heute schon den ganzen tag so gut bei
den baden wetter und ich dachte erst da
habe ich mich auch übergeben habe ich
glaube ich sage schon morgen um 15 uhr
in farbe arbeiten bei ihnen ja ja genau
dann melde ich mich am besten wenn es
mir besser geht das ist total nett waren
ich rufe jetzt bei so einem restaurant
an und sage dass ich durch ball nein zu
lenken
ja hier ist obi ich wollte ganz gut
bescheid sagen dass ich morgen leider
nicht zum arbeiten kommen kann weil ich
habe nach dem ersten gestern nach mehr
arbeiten gestern ausland jetzt schon mit
tobi ist ihr hobby ich wollte nur sagen
dass ich morgen nicht kommen kann
bitte nach 16 uhr muss ich morgen
wir sind ich bin nicht halten
diese nehme ich lieber zuhause flacht
also ich bin jetzt gerade nicht da ist
wo bin ich denn genau wurde
da habe ich mich mal mit sorry das ist
mir leider nicht verwertet ok danke dir
danke daten anschauen
[Gelächter]
da wird alles schon bei dem unternehmen
angerufen haben wollen allerdings jetzt
sarah und sandra noch mal zusammen
irgendwo anrufen
hallo anna schubert mein name ich habe
einen freund über letzten mal auf und
bleibt die entschuldigung ich habe eine
frage und zwar bis jetzt meinen augen
gehört morgen geht's ja ich hab ich
gesehen habe ich den job ja ich habe
meine ausbildung jetzt als hair
stylisten abgeschlossen ich wollte
fragen ob sie natürlich nicht hier
warum hallo
caro chantelle schubert meinen namen und
zwar habe ich meine ausbildung jetzt
abgeschlossen bald als erste an
ich wollte fragen ob sie vielleicht noch
sei aber nichts muss ich dann noch
aufschreiben so mama papa und so wir
auch gelegt
ich habe geburtstag bekomme ich noch was
kostenlos dazu außerdem ich hab
geburtstag so komme ich doch etwas
kostenlos dazu
ich habe geburtstag bekomme ich gesagt
noch das geschenk monaten
[Musik]
hallo ich es macd nun dass mein
spielzeug keine museen zeigen dass mir
das ist wie so ein auto nicht geschmeckt
freunde hatte bauchschmerzen ich hatte
ein bisschen bauchschmerzen aber ich
darf mich jetzt begrüßt und zu einem
neuen blog inhaltsstoff ding und zwar
hat das ganze etwas hiermit zu tun und
auch hier mit nintendogs viele leute
haben den wunsch geäußert dass ich mal
wieder den händler spieler deswegen
freunde hier
wir sind im hundezwinger und klopften
einfach mal an und kaufen uns einen
neuen balu
[Musik]
ich hatte dafür extra ein kleines intro
gebastelt wieder gar schon gesehen habt
ihr auch schon wahrscheinlich im intro
sehen können dass es einen golden
retriever dafür extra das moment ich
habe mir dieses spiel bestellt
nintendogs das hotel friends also wir
sind jetzt hier dinge zuletzt kann dem
speed film hier richtig jetzt einfach
nur noch golden retriever und werde mir
einen männchen oder weibchen schon
männchen oder bei username also das hier
ist der hund freunde erwischt ich jetzt
einfach mal auf bestätigen möchtest du
diesen grund da oben sehen wir ihnen
nochmal ganz ganz süßer und ich glaub ja
das heißt du hast dein hündchen gewählt
[Musik]
eine ewigkeit später
jetzt können wir nahmen die balu also
sieht das ganze jetzt hier aus freunde
wir haben hierbei jetzt bauen zu hause
weg schon hier unten werde jetzt auch
dynamik mit hier ankommen wir können den
streichen wir können ihm auch gleich
noch was zu essen kaufen mal in waschen
und so weiter und so fort aber das ganze
werden wir nicht jetzt und heute in
diesem blog machen das ganze hier
nämlich in den nächsten blogs passieren
und zwar immer mal hat uns also es kann
sein dass übermorgen
zwischendrin wieder mal eine band time
kommt das finde ich eigentlich ganz cool
es kann allerdings auch sein dass es in
blogs 47 wirklich kommen weil ich
unterwegs bin und in dsl wer nicht mit
habe aber ich werde immer mal
zwischendurch blut heim in diesem blog
mit drin haben für das ihr so ein
bisschen wieder nintendos von mir
bekommt und jetzt würde ich aber an
dieser stelle den block eigentlich auch
beenden ihr euch gefallen hat dann das
gerne mal ein live da geht er durch
dieses loch konzept eigentlich also wir
machen viel spaß weil ich möchte heute
konnte ich sagen machen wie diese train
calls aber jetzt auch gaming mit
nintendogs ich konnte blog machen
allgemeinen von jule zeigen also lasst
bleibt damit euch gefällt
[Musik]